hey youtubers is Charlie there's a new
Game of Thrones book being released in
about three weeks called a night of the
seven kingdoms but it's actually a
re-release of a couple old books called
the tales of Dunkin egg so this video is
going to be a primer for Dunkin egg if
you've never heard of them before you
have absolutely no idea what I'm talking
about
egg is Aegon v he's one of the future
kings of Westeros whenever this story is
being told now this is this is mostly
about his early years
Dunc was Sir Duncan the tall the person
who Aegon became squired to eventually
Aegon father was Prince maker the first
and there were so many Targaryen
brothers they had to figure out what to
do with the people that they thought
were not going to become king the funny
thing about that of course is Aegon did
end up becoming king but only after a
Great Council but that's way way down
the road the story that's told during
the Duncan egg series is mostly his
younger years like them going around the
Seven Kingdoms having adventures so a
lot of you guys asked is this story
important for understanding what's going
on in the main series in A Song of Ice
and Fire
well it is canon to the main series but
it's like reversed growth it'd be like
George Martin writing a book about
ancient Valyria you know it might offer
some insight as to what's going on with
the Song of Ice and Fire but not
necessarily it's mostly just intended to
be its own story you guys also might
have heard the duncan egg is the leading
candidate for the Game of Thrones
spin-off TV series just because it's so
well developed george RR martin has
spent so much time writing that story we
actually heard a Gon's name during
season five of Game of Thrones
when maester aemon was dying he started
hallucinating his childhood he started
calling out for egg his brother
egg egg mothers looking for you it was a
really sweet moment but it was huge if
you actually read the duncan egg series
because you learned all about these
crazy adventures that egg had and
especially what ended up happening to
him later in life those are almost like
two different stories but the actual
story of duncan egg starts with sir
Duncan the tall before he became a
knight he kind of starts out as like a
c-3po r2d2 type character you know
someone who isn't a really big deal in
the grand scheme of things but couple
accidents happen he gets swept up in
this larger adventure and you know he
becomes sir Duncan the tall eventually
so little history on sir Duncan the tall
first he started out living in flea
bottom that's actually where sir Davos
is from this is like the worst place you
could possibly live if you lived in
King's Landing
I think Davos actually said something
about rivers of flowing
where there sounds wonderful but as you
can imagine sir Duncan the tall got that
name because he was super tall like
mountain tall because of the environment
because of his upbringing he was kind of
an heir do well but by the age of 16 he
became squired to a night called sir
Arlen a penny tree if you remember
that's about the same age as Jon Snow
was whenever the first book picks up in
the first season of the TV show if you
guys are big game of Thrones history
buffs the really interesting thing is
that sir Arlen only chose dunk as his
new Squire because his old one died at
the Battle of red grass field that was
the big final battle of the first
Blackfyre rebellion of which the
Bloodraven was part of Brynden rivers
the Bloodraven of course is also the
three-eyed Raven that is now training
brand to become a green seer so you see
as the camera zooms out it's all
connected
so dunk becomes squired to sir arlen a
penny tree and if you're not familiar
with what a hedge Knight is they're kind
of like a ronin samurai they don't have
a master and they just wander around
looking for work so sir Arlen a penny
tree just travels around the Seven
Kingdoms going to tournaments trying to
win money so the very first story in the
dunk and egg series is called the hedge
Knight and as it's picking up sir Arlen
dies on the road to a new tournament
Dunc decides to use it as an opportunity
to raise his station in life so he
pretends that sir Arlen raised him
tonight hood before he died and tries to
ride to compete in the tournament
himself but on the way he also meets a
young bald boy named egg the boy begs to
become Duncan's Squire without telling
him his true identity he just he thinks
he's just some random kid that he found
on the road so they get to this
tournament which is an Ashford dunk
tries to join saying that starland
raised in tonight hood but nobody's
buying it and things start to get worse
and worse that night one of the
Targaryen Prince's that's there gets
super drunk and almost kills one of the
puppeteers that's entertaining people
dunk rushes in to save him and starts to
beat the crap out of this Targaryen
Prince so naturally the Kingsguard
rushes in in almost chops his head off
on the spot but egg reveals his true
identity and says hey I'm a con v I'm
one of the Targaryen princes don't harm
this man now that's really just the
beginning of things because egg ons
father was there with some of his other
brothers now at the time he was just
prince maker because he himself was the
fourth son so Aegon the fifth egg is
like the fourth son of a fourth
son so the odds of them becoming King
are very slim even though they actually
did end up becoming Kings but to get
himself out of the situation Dunc has to
do a seven-way trial by combat with the
prince that he was beating up if you've
never heard of a seven-way trial by
combat it's it's just like a trial by
combat this is their 7 combatants on
each side there's just a lot of people
going really crazy hoping that Cersei in
Game of Thrones season 6 when she has
her trial with the faith chooses
seven-way trial by combat if that
actually ends up being the case for real
I would actually think it'd be the high
Sparrow they would choose to turn it
into a seven-way trial by combat just
just because he would see Robert strong
be like well no one person can beat him
so why don't we get seven that's just
speculation though I really hope we do
get to see the TV show do a seven-way of
trial by combat before it's over though
so as the book starts to come out we can
talk more and more about the separate
adventures that Duncan take have as they
go around the Seven Kingdoms but just
looking at other series this reminds me
a lot of the King Arthur Chronicles like
like the once and future king by th
white whereby Merlyn ends up helping
raise King Arthur it's like you know the
boy who would be king one day but even
though it might seem like egg is the big
character in this story because he's
gonna grow up to be a Gahan v king of
Westeros a lot of its told from sir
Duncan the tall sper spective
because he's viewing this boy grow up to
become a king so it's actually a really
good story that expands the mythology of
A Song of Ice and Fire it's it's cannon
to the main series but you don't have to
read it to understand what's going on in
the main series and if you're not really
big on reading books they did turn it
into a graphic novel several years ago
you can actually buy it on Amazon I know
a lot of you are really big on the audio
books too I would assume that is part of
this big re-release of these stories
that they'll also release an audio
version just a quick reminder to new
round of the giveaway starts now it's
going to be a $20 Amazon gift card in a
couple weeks when they do release the
new book I'll just use that for the
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video I know a lot of you guys
have been asking me about stuff that's
going on with Game of Thrones on this
set there have been a lot of pictures of
Maisie Williams mostly stuff from her
storyline and winds of winter so it's
kind of spoilery I'm not going to go
super deep into it but if you do want to
know all about it just read the Mersey
preview from winds of winter some of you
have also asked about the Jon Snow stuff
the people are talking about on the set
I've already done a whole bunch of
videos about how I think that he is
coming back so I'll put some links in
the description if there are any special
requests that you guys have for next
week's bonus video though just let me
know in the comments
so while you guys wait for next week's
bonus video and Walking Dead tonight you
can click here to learn all about
resurrection on Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire
and you can click here for my season six
predictions thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you